For two weeks this February,
the infinity chili pepper
held the world record
for being the hottest pepper on Earth;
so dangerous, it was hotter
than the chemicals used in hand grenades
by the Indian military.
But is the infinity chili pepper
the best hot pepper of all time?
Not anymore—
to find out why,
all aboard the BOAT.
[BOAT]
[♪ music ♪]
Let's begin
with what makes hot peppers hot—
a chemical called capsaicin.
It's not acidic or anything—
in fact, it's an alkaline oil,
and the unique shape
of the molecule
means that it does
some pretty weird things to mammals.
Mammals have a specific type
of nerve cell that detects pain
from heat and abrasion—
now, what's weird about capsaicin
is that it will attach
to those receptors
and cause calcium ions
to flow in,
making us think
that we're burning or that we're injured,
and that's why hot peppers
are hot.
The heat of a pepper is measured
in Scoville Heat Units.
The basic way they calculate this
is by seeing how much you have to dilute
an extract of the pepper
before nobody can taste it
in a glass of sugar water.
Coming in at zero Scoville heat units
are things like bell peppers,
which have no noticeable heat.
Between 100 and 500,
you'll find things like banana peppers
and the little pimentos
inside olives.
Jalapenos and Tabasco sauce
can rate as high
as 8,000 Scoville heat units,
but habaneros
can rate as high
as 350,000.
But that's just kid stuff—
at the beginning of this episode,
I mentioned the infinity chili,
which for two weeks in February
was the world record holder
for hottest pepper,
but then in the middle of February,
a man in the UK
named Gerald Fowler cross-bred
two of the hottest peppers on Earth,
the Bhut Jolokia
and the Naga Morich,
to create a child pepper
that he called the Naga Viper.
Laboratories tested the pepper
and found that on the Scoville scale,
it ranked in
at 1.3 million,
making it the current world record holder
for hottest pepper on Earth,
but the race continues.
Just a couple of months ago,
a new strain
of the Trinidad Scorpion emerged,
simply called Butch T.
A lab that tested it found
that it ranked
at 1.4 million Scoville Heat Units—
so hot that in order to cook with it,
the cultivators
had to wear chemical masks
and body suits
and felt numbness in their hands
for more than two days.
When its measurements become official,
it will be the reigning champ
for hottest pepper,
but let's stop talking
about edible peppers
and move on to things that are weapons.
1.4 million Scoville Heat Units—
please.
Law enforcement-grade pepper spray
clocks in
at 5.5 million.
[spraying sounds]
[coughing sounds]
And pure capsaicin is so dangerous,
it has its own fire diamond warning code in the US.
On the scale, pure capsaicin sits
way up at 16 million.
Oh, but we're not even done there.
Capsaicin can't get any hotter,
but it does have molecular analogs
that are more dangerous.
The resin spurge is a cactus
found in Morocco.
It's not a pepper,
and it doesn't contain capsaicin,
but it does contain
a waxy latex substance
that works just like capsaicin,
except 1,000 times more efficiently.
It's called resiniferatoxin.
Just like capsaicin,
resiniferatoxin attaches to those cells
responsible for feeling abrasion
and heat pain,
but instead of stimulating them
by letting a little bit of calcium in,
it lets so much calcium in
that the nerve cell walls break
and the cell dies.
What this means
is that resiniferatoxin
is so hot,
it actually doesn't always cause pain.
It'll just cause the death of cells
that make you feel pain.
For this reason,
doctors have found
that if they inject doses
of resiniferatoxin into the spinal cords of dogs
suffering pain because
of terminal bone cancer,
those dogs will feel no pain
and be able to play
and frolic for months afterwards.
So what are you waiting for?
Get out there and order
some jalapeno poppers and feel the heat.
Speaking of the heat,
I'm going to be in Miami this weekend.
In fact, I'm probably flying there right now—
Kevin helped me upload this video.
Next week, we've got
some really awesome stuff.
IMG, Loot, and a new episode
of Vsauce Lean Back I'm very excited about.
So stay tuned, and as always,
thanks for watching.
[Vsauce 2]